these marine biologists are hunting for
an almost mythical creature it has the
head of a horse the tail of a serpent
and an insect like armor of bony plates
but it's really a fish the niceness even
though it's a little male scratch small
as you can see it's frequent it's
interesting because a lot of people
think Theo Cesare Monica fairytale not
many people actually believe
seamlessness exists there are only about
35 species of seahorses and biologists
fear for their survival
these fish are extremely fragile they
only eat live brine shrimp and are
sensitive to small changes in their
habitats pollution boats and fluctuating
water temperatures can easily destroy
whole colonies
that's why marine biologists have come
here to South Africa to study one of the
rarest seahorses the NIH's none they
have no idea how many niceness seahorses
there are but they exist nowhere else on
earth
mark nathi is part of a team of
volunteer divers trying to map Najma
seahorse habitats the seals is on the
endangered species list
not not because of the numbers because
we didn't actually know before this
project harmony they were but because
they only occur in these two histories
one natural disaster could walk the
matter
County and seahorse's is easy the water
often iyslah is under 14 degrees Celsius
and visibility close to zero
the divers follow a slender line that
delineates the search area then comb
through it thick carpet of seaweed sea
horses like chameleons change color to
hide the male's wrap their slender tails
around the green stalks and sway like
the weeds
the divers carefully measure each little
seahorse and record observations and
notebooks the fish are replaced where
they're found to minimize any disruption
in their feeding and mating habits pairs
mate for life
the female providing the eggs to the
male who fertilizes them in his pouch
and carries the young and till they
hatch I guess the the unique
reproductive strategy that that they
have with the the male falling pregnant
and giving birth to the young I think
that's very unusual there's not many
animal species not many fish species
that have that reversal in sex roles
once the biologists know more about
these fragile seahorses they hope to
come up with better ways to protect them